spüren wir endlich die dunkle energie
auf der start des deutschen
röntgenteleskop zero sita mitte juli ist
eine riesige chance für die astronomie
vorausgegangen war dem eine 14
jahrelange planung und die chancen
stehen nicht schlecht dass die usa
endlich licht ins geheimnis der dunklen
energie bringen können die klicks um
science-fiction jetzt täglich
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen am ende wurde es
noch einmal richtig spannend denn
insgesamt zweimal wurde der start des
deutschen röntgenteleskop sie rosita
verschoben
eigentlich sollte die rakete schon am 21
juni abheben doch probleme mit einer
batterie verhinderten diesen plan auch
ein weiterer geplanter start mitte juli
musste aufgrund technischer probleme
abgesagt werden doch der start am 13
juli 2009 10 vom weltraumbahnhof
baikonur in kasachstan verlief dann
bilderbuchmäßig und 14 uhr 31 deutscher
zeit hob die russische trägerrakete dann
ohne zwischenfälle ab an bord ein
russisches teleskop und das deutsche
röntgenteleskop musiker auf dem äußerst
große hoffnungen schon 2005 hatten
forschungsteams von max planck institut
für extraterrestrische physik die ersten
pläne für us etat vorgelegt 2007 wurden
verträge unterschrieben und eigentlich
sah der plan vor bereits 2011 ins all zu
starten doch es gab riesige probleme vor
allem bei der entwicklung der spiegel
letztendlich setzten sich die teleskop
module nun aus insgesamt 54
langgezogenen spiegel schaden zusammen
die mit gold beschichtet sind so gelang
es den fachleuten genügend spiegelfläche
zu schaffen die auch aus den tiefen des
alls zu röntgen nicht empfangen können
dazu heißt es vom deutschen zentrum für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr 7 parallel
ausgerichtete spiegelsystem bilden die
optik des röntgenteleskop ihre
kombination aus licht sammeln fläche
gesichtsfeld und auflösungsvermögen ist
bisher unerreicht im brennpunkt jedes
spiegelsystem sitzt eine
hochempfindliche ccd kamera
probleme gab es aber auch mit dem
missionskreis ursprünglich sollte er
sieht in einer niedrigen umlaufbahn
verweilen dann aber wurde um entschieden
und das röntgenteleskop würzig 1,5
millionen kilometer von der erde
entfernt und somit den sogenannten
zweiten punkt erreichen das ist ein
punkt eben 1,5 millionen kilometer
jenseits der erdumlaufbahn um die sonne
an dem sondern aufgrund der gravitation
von erde und sonne mit der gleichen
winkel geschwindigkeit um die sonne
kreisen wie die erde
die position zur erde also antriebslos
dauerhaft halten können genau hier soll
auch das heiß ersehnte james webb
weltraumteleskop positioniert werden das
riesige teleskop soll aber erst im märz
2021 staaten auch die auswahl der
raketen gestaltete sich extrem schwierig
zunächst wollte man auf eine russische
sojus setzen
letztendlich wurde es dann aber die
proton eine schwerlast rakete aus
russland die in den vergangenen jahren
einige fehlschläge zu verbuchen hatte
nach dem start mitte juli also konnten
die fachleute mit recht erst einmal
aufatmen
nun steht die dreimonatige reise der eu
haben dabei wird sie immer mal wieder
getestet und stück für stück in betrieb
genommen dann geht die richtige arbeit
erst los und die ist nicht ohne denn sie
soll tatsächlich eine art kosmische
inventur des universums ermöglichen
galaxien die milliarden lichtjahre
entfernt sind können mit hilfe des
röntgen teleskops in bislang
unerreichter auflösung erforscht werden
letztendlich soll dann eine himmelskarte
entstehen die nicht weniger als die
entwicklung des universums abbildet
röntgenstrahlung soll das alles
ermöglichen und die strukturen das als
sichtbar machen deswegen auch der name
eu sieht der für extended rating
telescope array steht also erweiterte
röntgenuntersuchungen mit mehreren
bildgebenden teleskopen im visier stehen
nicht nur verdunkelte schwarze löcher in
nahen galaxien und röntgenquellen wie
etwa supernova überreste in unserer
galaxie untersucht werden sollen vor
allem bis zu 100.000 galaxienhaufen also
ansammlungen von tausenden einzelaktien
die durch die gravitation miteinander
verbunden sind
möglich wird deren analyse durch das gas
das sich in ihnen befindet und bis zu
100 millionen grad heiß ist wegen dieser
hohen temperatur sendet es
röntgenstrahlung aus die fachleute
wollen durch die verteilung der
galaxienhaufen herausfinden wie sich das
universum ausdehnt wie es damals aussah
und natürlich auch wie es heute aussieht
bis zu 6 milliarden jahre soll die
musiker zurückblicken können und hier
kommt dann auch die dunkle energie ins
spiel eine mysteriöse kraft die das
universum auseinandertreibt und über die
experten und expertinnen weltweit nur
sehr wenig wissen warum den sich das
universum seit dem urknall weiter aus
obwohl diese expansion eigentlich durch
die gravitation der materie verlangsamt
werden sollte klar ist falls es gelingt
verschiedene charakteristika der
galaxienhaufen zu bestimmen würden diese
erkenntnisse rückschlüsse auf die dunkle
energie zu lassen konkret interessieren
sich die forschungsteams für die masse
an zahl und entfernung der
galaxienhaufen um daraus dann die dichte
des universums zu unterschiedlichen
zeiten seiner ausdehnung zu berechnen
dazu sagt peter praet der
verantwortliche astronom vom max planck
institut für extraterrestrische physik
wir werden die dunkle energie zwar nicht
dingfest machen aber wir werden aus
unseren messwerten hoffentlich
rückschlüsse ziehen können um was es
sich dabei handelt die musiker könnte
also eine antwort auf die wohl
faszinierendste frage der astronomie und
für sie geben und das wiederum könnte
eine fundamentale revolution der physik
mit sich bringen wie das
max-planck-institut für
extraterrestrische physik auf seiner
webseite schreibt doch dafür brauchen
wir wohl noch etwas geduld denn die
expertinnen und experten gehen davon aus
dass das ganze vier jahre dauern wird
den himmel komplett zu erfassen dafür
dass die russen den start von rosita
durchgeführt haben geht übrigens die
hälfte der daten zu ihnen dunkle materie
die suche nach dem unsichtbaren
anklicken anschauen und du unbedingt
raumzeit block der zukunft abonnieren
richtig cooler kanal bis dann bleibt
dran also hier draufklicken unbedingt